[Music]
ok everyone I'm really excited today
because it's not every day you get to
talk to a legendary comedic actress but
I have the privilege today to talk to
Riki Lindhome as Kimberly on duncanville
you might know her from Garfunkel and
Oates another period and she was
recently also in knives out
Riki how you doing today I'm good how
are you doing good so I wanted to talk a
little bit about Kimberly on Duncanville
who you voice and it's so interesting to
me because when I first heard Kimberly's
character the voice in a good way was so
unrecognizable and I really would think
it was like a 12 year old and I want to
know funny my mom is like it freaked out
by it because she has flat because it's
exactly how I founded it 12 and my mom
watches it and had flashbacks she's like
I picture you like yelling as a 12 year
old oh my god that see that that's so
interesting to me because I wonder do
you tap in then to your like 12 year old
Ricky to get into this character of
Kimberly yeah totally I mean my voice
isn't that far off from like a emotional
preteen like that's kind of enclosed but
yeah I just make it like a little higher
a little more vocal fry' you know yeah
and then a little more high-stakes
emotion so when you're also doing this
voice acting I wonder is it more
challenging in the sense of connecting
with the other characters because you're
not all on set there when you're voice
acting it's I'm guessing most of the
time just you what are the cool things
we do is what we do a table read every
week at box will now they're unzoom but
we do a table reads that you get to hear
how everyone's doing the voices you kind
of get how people are gonna play the
scene so then we record alone and also
if you're if you're kind of off like the
director will tell you like oh that
structures yelling or whatever it is but
in you and you give them choices you
know like every line you give them at
least three takes on it right so
when you're actually going in and doing
a scene for Kimberly are you most of the
time the first one putting your voice in
are you hearing also some that are
already recorded and done by other
characters mostly it's just you putting
your voice in the only time when you're
with other characters if you're like
saying something in unison like if you
have to sing something or doing a chance
or whatever it is you chant along with
another pre-recorded actor but mostly
it's just you and you just do it line by
line like you don't even do the whole
scene you just do the one line over and
over and then you go to the next line
and do that over and over so that's
that's really interesting so animation
is the script then more rigid like is
there room for improv are you just going
right to what's on the page I mostly go
to what's on the page because the
duncanville scripts are so funny
that they don't really need me to add
anything if I had some improv on
something I I would do it but I'd
usually give them three takes is what
they wrote and then be like oh I want to
try this one thing I pretty much quit
because it's already good yeah no and I
wondered - are you seeing the images in
front of you like in full motion or
these static images or there are there
even images of Kimberly in front you
know so basically we do the table read
and then we go and you just record you
know no images nothing you record and
then like nine months later you'll see
sometimes can you'll have to do some
sort of a TRS and because there's always
like an extra movement or an extra like
a little space we have to say something
so that's when you do it along with your
characters characters image but mostly
you just do it and then they animate to
your voice okay so that's interesting
too because you're actually experienced
with the voice acting and you actually
recently did poison ivy in the batman
lego movie so that's awesome I mean what
was that like kind of playing an iconic
character but in like Lego form and did
it was it challenging at all it was
great well he Knight actually written a
song for that movie and at the last
minute they they had what kind of
sequence that our song was in and they
didn't so it didn't make the movie but
they're like well you want to come do
voices and we're both like yeah so we
went a minute did voices like it was
sort of like the consolation prize but
it ended up being like a great
consolation prize yeah
that's that's really cool and I wonder
too because you've done a good amount of
voice work but you obviously have done
so much comedic acting and regular
acting in general showing some really
good chops and knives out in particular
I can remember in recent memory I mean
can you just compare for me like maybe
the pros and cons of acting on a set or
just doing a voiceover in animation Pro
acting on a set is definitely like the
camaraderie you just you get to be
around people you just have that energy
you get to play off of someone and it's
just like exciting you know you go in
and your hair and makeup and your
wardrobe and you know you get to have
that whole like playing pretend
experience so there's that's the probe
at and voiceover takes an hour so either
so and it takes an hour and then you're
done yeah it's just there's you know
different pros and cons I guess so I
have to ask to about three weeks ago on
your Instagram you posted a picture
saying you know
Kimberly's back season two and it looks
like you're in studio so is season two
all already recorded are you guys still
like in the process of no so this is
what's fascinating so they picked it up
and the writers are writing in a zoom
like a virtual writers room okay and
then we do zoom table reads the whole
cast does the table room the executive
watch it and give notes or whatever
feedback and then we they have like
basically a Kovan safe recording booth
we have different entrances the
engineers in one room you know glass
wall and you're in a like another room
all by yourself
and you hear direction from the director
and creators in headphones so it's a
little strange where you're just yeah
you're just totally yeah they made it
covert say so we are recording in a in
we are going in to record but it's at a
different place than normal so do you
think saying that it sounds very
effective and actually is amazing how in
these times we can still make a show
like this do you think that animation
right now is in like a Renaissance
period it will kind of be more the
future now because of the current
situation I think so I mean it depends
on how long the you know the pandemic
goes on but you know it seems
guess the only thing that'd be actually
right now you can write things right now
a lot of things but to actually get
after like we just don't know when
that's going to be what is gonna be
faced oh so you think even like a Lego
Batman let's say another movie that
comes out that could be made now yeah I
don't see why not
you know it's sort of you know probably
extra back and forth because there is
something you know more like faster
about this being in the same room and
coming up with ideas together or doing
edits or whatever but it's probably a
lot more back and forth but there's no
reason it can't be done that's
encouraging and I think that gives hope
just to the entertainment and people
getting new content as a whole so that's
good to hear
just sort of quick back to Duncanville I
want to ask you for all the big fans of
the show if you had to pick your
favorite moment of kimberley so far in
season 1 what would that be um I think
the moment when she gets when she's like
making out with a balloon that looks
like wolf and it could it's stuck in her
braces I think that's probably her most
embarrassing moment aka my favorite
moment I love that so with Kimberly what
can we look forward to for season 2 with
her character you can give us any hints
I'm not totally sure well you know I
believe read the first episode so no
first two episodes so basically you know
more more crushes lots of she she
already had some crushes and more a
rivalry with Duncan I don't know there
hasn't been a Kimberly Focus episode yet
so I don't know exactly what her
storyline will be but but so far you
know and you know she might get a little
girl up this season too
okay I like that no crazy time jump
though or anything like that and before
I let you go Ricky I have to ask I was
just blown away by your Instagram post I
think it's like a day ago but these
onion goggles that's all
I'm gonna say just oh yeah that was
yesterday I have really sensitive eyes
and I you know I never really cooked
before the pandemic but now you kind of
have to learn and so I'm chopping onions
and I just cry and it hurts my eyes so
badly that I bought onion goggles on
Amazon and I I wear goggles when I chop
onion and then that's what's incredible
it's it's a hysterical post you put but
it also is a revelation to people like
knees I didn't know this was a thing so
now it's something I think many people
run to order because of you yeah it's so
funny I was like I was like I wonder
onions all over this and I didn't go
girl in yes they do I'm like okay so
other people have this problem Ricky it
was such a pleasure to talk to you
everyone please change yeah yeah and
check out the comic-con panel tomorrow
at 12 p.m. with the whole cast of
Duncanville including Ricky and the
newcomers Wiz Khalifa rashida Jones and
many more the link to that video will be
in description down below watch
Duncanville on Fox Fox now and Hulu and
season two in my correct is we're aiming
for next spring on Fox right yeah okay
okay cool Ricky's or anything else you
wanted to plug before I let you go no I
mean I guess yes as you get humour but
you also get just to learn you learn
from your Instagram and yeah and
obviously if you're a big fan of Ricky
if you want to see some great Hamilton
singing and rapping check it out yep
same to you bye